yesterday on the view the view is the
daytime talk show on ABC that has really
been a bigger and bigger part of the
2020 election you've seen a lot of the
Democratic presidential candidates stop
by you've seen Donald Trump talking
about the hosts they're part of the
milieu so to speak they talked about the
Bernie Warren situation in advance of
yesterday's debate of course Bernie
Sanders accused of telling a Elizabeth
Warren that a woman can't win
Bernie denied that during yesterday's
debate and everything went crazy and the
the disheartening thing is that they
basically on the view accepted the story
hook line and sinker without even
questioning the meeting of the meaning
of what Bernie is accused of saying so
I've got a bunch of different clips to
play for you here other than one example
from Joy Behar which I will get to this
is how these stories spread
CNN reports at Monday the view talks
about at Tuesday basically not
questioning the story CNN asks about it
in their own debate Tuesday night and
now it's a major story in the Democratic
primary which helps merely to prop up
the de facto establishment leader which
is Joe Biden so first of all let's go to
the first clip where they present as a
foregone conclusion that Bernie
obviously said that a woman can't win
Marn confirmed rumors that back in 2018
Bernie told her he doesn't think a women
woman could win the presidency
Bernie denies it saying he told her that
you know who has a sexist racist thing
he's a lyin he would weaponize anything
he could but he does believe a woman
could win since Hillary beat
you-know-who by 3 million votes last
so if this gonna be a talking point is
this more drama for the sake of Ronald
Bloods mom and dad Melissa Warren was
keeping this in her back pocket right
she kept the receipts because I think
they made the pact when they got
together in her apartment saying look
we're we have the same message we gotta
win this thing so let's not tear each
other apart and then that happens and
she's like well fine if you're gonna
play the game that I'm gonna play too so
here Abby Huntsman presents it as a fair
tit-for-tat that Bernie did something
and Warren responded but what did Bernie
do we now know that indeed Bernie in
some early states deployed an anti-war
inscript
attacking Elizabeth Warren for appealing
to highly educated elites you can
disagree with the strategy you can say
well Bernie and Warren had agreed not to
do that and Bernie did it and that's
between them but that's just normal
politics accusing Bernie of saying
something if he didn't say it is very
different so so equating that is it is
unfair and later on once again that this
idea of surrogates trashing Warren is
equivalent I think they're they're a bit
different but what's interesting is that
they did have this pact and they have
been friends for a long time but when
she found out that his surrogates were
out there as she said trashing her she
did come out and say he doesn't think a
woman can win and I don't he's denying
it but I don't doubt that he perhaps
said that I mean we've had 45 presidents
they've all been men all right so it's
he may very well think that but they'd
rather vote for 78 year old socialists
who just had a heart attack than a woman
III think I think
it is probably accurate but they've got
to get together so now it's really a
mess sunny Hostin says well once Bernie
trashed Warren Warren came out and said
Bernie said a woman can't win is that
actually what happened and if so does
sunny Hostin know about some
coordination between Elizabeth Warren
and CN n because as far as the public
facing narrative goes CNN ran the story
Monday Warren was asked and confirmed it
but they seem to be suggesting Bernie
did a so Warren did B is that actually
the way it went down because if Warren's
involvement is that we should know that
that's very different than the story
that's being told Bernie is accused here
of something that he has denied by CNN
and then Warren had the opportunity to
confirm or deny and she said yeah that's
the way it went down it's very
coincidental timing right before the
debate on CNN so then in comes Joy Behar
with the they want to vote for a 78 year
old socialist who had a heart attack
instead of a woman again reinforcing the
idea of Bernie followers as sexist now
at one point to her credit Joy Behar
does raise the point of is it sexist to
point out that sexism might prevent a
woman from winning which I've now been
saying for two days check that out I
don't see why this is big news so two
people are in agreement because I'd love
to hear what you say but like so people
are in a room and they're talking and
one person says gee do you think a woman
can win the race in this country and the
other one goes I don't know about that I
mean everybody has conversations like
that why is this a big story well it was
made a big story by ignoring that
context hey if I say I doubt a Jewish
candidate can win because of
anti-semitism and anti-zionism
if I say I doubt a Muslim candidate can
win because of Islamophobia okay well we
can debate that but it's not
Islamophobic to point that out saying i
doubt a woman can win because of sexism
and because of attitudes towards women
that is okay to say and I'm glad Joy
Behar brings it up although it was not
the context of the conversation nor of
the conversation during last night's
debate then Megan McCain comes in and
says hey I'm a Republican and sexism is
bad misogyny is bad trump sexism and
misogyny are bad and I don't want
another misogynist in the Oval Office
likening Donald Trump to Bernie which is
mind blowing ly crazy
take a look I'm sure I will have my
Twitter just lit up on fire because of
this but he has a problem with women and
he has for a long time and I think if
Elizabeth Warren has this in her back
pocket all's fair in politics all's fair
in love and war and I think look I don't
want him another misogynist as president
no okay I mean I think we're all women
in this country are sick of it and I
have always thought he has yeah we don't
want Bernie because we already had
misogynist sexist Trump and we don't
want another one that's a crazy take I
mean that is just a straight-up unhinged
take so again this was the conclusion
during our debate analysis and it once
again is the conclusion all of this
narrative started with the CNN article
perpetuated by Elizabeth Warren
perpetuated yesterday on the view and
then again last night during the debate
with CNN literally after Bernie says I
didn't say it going to Warren and saying
how did you feel when Bernie said that
oh he denied it yeah we're not even
gonna mention that in asking you the
question it's a complete and total mess
which reinforces the status quo which is
you've got an establishment candidate
Joe Biden with a plurality of the vote
and the more this becomes a
back-and-forth oh maybe Bernie loses a
couple points here or gains a couple
points or Warren gains loses a couple it
keeps Joe Biden at roughly 30% and in a
position where he is the most likely
person to secure the nomination that may
have been the goal all along